does DC's The Flash get a gold medal or
does this long-awaited movie limp across
the Finish Line here's what the first
reviews have to say about the flash
let's get nuts few films can claim to
have the kind of press as The Flash and
the lead up to its release after
spending years in development Hell the
movie finally started making progress
with director Andy musketti at the
helmet starring Ezra Miller as the
Scarlet Speedster however Miller's well
documented instances of criminal
Behavior have tainted what was otherwise
highly anticipated movie it's especially
dire considering that the film was meant
to set up the future of the DC
live-action Cinematic Universe which
will soon have James Gunn and Peter
saffron at the steering wheel Warner
Brothers in DC have downplayed Miller's
involvement and instead focused on how
this could be one of the greatest
superhero movies ever made everyone from
Tom Cruise to Stephen King got early
screamings and raved about the flash to
anyone who would listen such reviews
combined with the return of Michael
Keaton as Batman certainly makes a film
an enticing Prospect even to people who
haven't necessarily been following DC's
latest cinematic outings but the
question remains how good is The Flash
really does it live up to the hype or
was it all a marketing Tech at First
Look it seems as though the flash
certainly isn't without its merits it's
currently standing at a 72 positive
rating on Rotten Tomatoes with 53
reviews as of the making of this video
many critics praise Ezra Miller's
performance as well as strong turns from
actors new and old to DC's Universe Ben
Affleck it's time to shine his Batman
before Michael Keaton takes over those
duties in an alternate timeline but
cameos aside it seems as though critics
have really taken to the emotional story
beats that make up the flash the film
draws heavily from the flashpoint
storyline in the comics where flash
travels back in time to save his mother
only to create an alternate timeline the
same happens in the movie and the
underlying story of Barry Allen trying
to find his place as a superhero while
maintaining his family gives the film
some much needed weight Brandon Zachary
of CBR rights The Flash is a
surprisingly emotional film exploring
Concepts like the inevitability of
mortality even in a world of Limitless
potential the consistent undercurrent of
grief and loss keeps the stakes High it
sees moments that apparently help the
movie stand up on its own two feet even
during more questionable moments David
Rooney of The Hollywood Reporter said
just the flash isn't perfect still that
core concept helps carry it through
according to one critic if the flash
ultimately proves uneven it's wobbly
climactic Showdown far less interesting
than the more character-driven build up
the story's core of a young man
struggling to reconcile with the loss of
his mother carries it through
interestingly a film build is the second
coming of superhero movies has more to
offer when it's focused more on
characters than spectacle in the
audience's enjoyment of such grander
moments may vary without getting into
spoilers The Flash seemingly does a lot
there's time travel alternate timelines
and different versions of the same
superheroes including some surprising
cameos the movie wants to have its cake
and eat it too but many critics think
that the film stumbles more often than
it flies there might not be a future in
Ross bunyam's review for collider
there's praise for certain story
elements But ultimately this is a film
that's unable to stand on its own two
feet the critic concluded unfortunately
this isn't a story that holds together
on a narrative level cameos and fan
service are fine to have but the story
has to be there to back them up and it's
not quite there with
there's little doubt certain cameos may
be enough to make General audiences
forgive some of the movie's poor moments
but critics are seen right through them
especially as the film drags on like so
many big action movies before it the
flash ends with a CGI late in final
battle that critics are already panning
one negative take came from Peter
Bradshaw the guardian who wrote despite
some diverting touches Miller's smirking
gurning mugging doppelganger performance
is a trial and in any case gets lost in
the inevitable third act CGI battle
apocalypse which is weightlessly free of
Jeopardy and like the rest of the film
does not exactly go by in the flash
there's a wide range of opinions with
some thinking the film's one of the best
superhero flicks of the 21st century
While others view it as another DC
letdown and coming out on the heels of
the nearly universally acclaimed
Spider-Man across the spider-verse may
not help matters either people can make
up their own minds when the flash comes
out on June 16th